this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by surf shark
despite it being humanity's constant
companion through all of recorded time
the moon is still a mystery science
hasn't been able to explain how the moon
was formed its unusual orbit its
distance from us its density its
composition its structure these are all
still questions now there are theories
about the moon that solve some of these
puzzles but they don't solve all of them
there's only one theory that answers
every scientific question about the moon
just one but the moon is a hollow
artificial structure brought here by
someone else
let's find out why
let's start at the beginning we're
taught that the moon has been here
forever but there's controversy about
this because scientists can't agree on
how the moon was formed in the first
place the first theory of how the moon
became linked to the earth is the
capture theory it says the moon was just
floating along drifted near the earth
and was pulled into orbit
this is almost impossible another
explanation is the accretion theory that
the moon and earth formed out of dust
clouds in the early solar system but
when systems form through accretion they
share similar traits if the moon was
formed this way it would have an iron
core like the earth it would spin on an
axis like the earth but neither of these
are true the fission hypothesis was
popular for a while and this says the
early earth was spinning so fast that
the moon was formed out of rock in the
pacific ocean that was flung into space
but we later learned that moon rock is
much older than the bottom of the ocean
so this is unlikely the most popular
explanation is the giant impact theory
this says that a large object about the
size of mars smashed into the
proto-earth the debris field from the
collision coalesced to create the earth
moon system again these conditions would
have to be so perfect that the odds are
astronomical right now a recent theory
is a combination of all of these that a
large object collided with the earth
about four and a half billion years ago
essentially vaporizing it and this vapor
is called a synestia and the cenestia
was spinning very rapidly forming a
taurus and the moon formed on the edge
of this taurus
hold on taurus oh what's a taurus well
this shape is a taurus uh that looks
like a donut it does but in geometry if
you revolve a circle around an axis in
three-dimensional space it's called a
taurus
and you wonder why you're not popular at
parties
i'm very popular at parties
aren't i
[Music]
so we still don't know how the moon was
created you would think that actually
going to the moon and collecting rock
samples would solve some of these
puzzles but when moon rocks were brought
back and studied it only created more
questions
[Music]
since landing on the moon in 1969
the moon landing was as fake as a
teenager's instagram i knew you were
gonna do this look do you like the idea
that the moon is a hollow spaceship well
yeah i gotta admit i i do kind of like
this idea okay so for us to explore this
theory you need to concede that we went
to the moon
fine i will concede we went to the moon
thank you but those were unmanned
missions the landings were actually
filmed in a studio in bear bay
california fine uh i'll take what i can
get
moon rocks and soil samples brought back
from the moon are strange on earth the
newest rocks are at the surface and the
rock gets older as you go deeper this is
obvious and logical but on the moon the
soil on the surface is older than the
rocks underneath
and the surface rocks are older than the
rock underneath them it's backwards the
only way this happens on earth is when
we drill dig and mine bringing older
material to the surface but we see this
all over the moon now if the moon was
somehow hollowed out older rock would be
on top but the list of anomalies goes on
typical planetary structures have denser
materials toward the core and lighter
materials toward the surface on the moon
this too is reversed and no one could
really explain why the moon's surface is
pockmarked by asteroid impacts that have
happened for billions of years so you
would expect the rock around the impact
craters to be different ages but there
is a strange uniformity in the age of
these rocks the chemical makeup of lunar
dust is also very odd if lunar dust is
the result of billions of years of
impacts why does it have a different
chemical makeup of the rocks around it
the moon doesn't have a magnetic field
yet moon rocks are strongly magnetized
the earth is 4.6 billion years old but
the oldest rocks we found are much
younger than that moon rocks are older
much older some rocks have been dated to
the very beginning of the solar system
and some are said to be even older than
that
uranium-236
and
neptunium-237 are found on the moon
this is notable because those
radioactive elements don't occur
naturally the only way we see those
isotopes on earth is if we create them
titanium chromium and zirconium are rare
on earth but these are found in
abundance on the moon if the earth and
moon were formed together why such a big
discrepancy and those metals happen to
be some of the most strongest materials
that are known to exist and they're
highly resistant to corrosion if you
wanted to reinforce a structure these
are the metals you would use this
structural reinforcement could explain
why moon craters all seem to be the same
depth no matter how wide they are
shouldn't craters of different sizes be
of different depths
it's as if there's a resilient metallic
shell just beneath the surface of the
moon preventing anything from
penetrating further now if there was
some type of instruments on the moon's
surface that could detect seismic
activity we could test the hollow moon
theory by intentionally colliding
objects with the moon this sounds like a
setup we did this didn't we we did and
is it hollow well hey y'all
[Music]
after returning to the command module
the apollo 12 crew intentionally
released the lunar lander crashing it
into the moon's surface then something
very unexpected happened seismic
measurements showed that the moon rang
like a bell and reverberated for more
than an hour this was with a very small
object compared to the size of the moon
so during apollo 13 an even heavier
object was crashed into the surface this
time the moon rang for over three hours
and vibrations traveled to a depth of 20
miles this doesn't happen on earth
reverberations last only a few minutes
because of the earth's density and on
earth vibrations slow down as they move
toward the earth's center where material
is denser but the vibrations on the moon
actually got faster around 40 miles down
indicating the interior of the moon is
not only far less dense but perhaps has
large hollow cavities the density of the
moon is something that's difficult to
explain the moon is about 25 the size of
the earth but it's only about one
percent of the earth's density if the
moon were a hollow shell this would
explain that besides the density issue
the moon has a lot of characteristics
and coincidences that we don't see
anywhere else the moon is actually more
like a planet than a moon at one quarter
of the earth's size no other object in
the solar system has a moon this large
this occurs nowhere else not in our
solar system or any other solar system
that we found and the moon orbits much
more closely than it should and its
orbit is also a mystery it's the only
object we've ever observed with a near
perfectly circular orbit we don't see
this anywhere else either because of
this near perfect orbit and its size and
distance from the earth the moon appears
in the sky as almost the exact same size
as the sun this is what allows us to
have eclipses
our distance to the sun is 400 times our
distance to the moon and the size of the
sun is 400 times the size of the moon
could this be a coincidence yeah
well when enough coincidences pile up we
may have to adjust our thinking and be a
little more open-minded and that's what
happened in 1970 two soviet scientists
looked at all the evidence and all these
coincidences and came to what they felt
was the only logical conclusion and they
agreed that their theory sounded crazy
but said not only is the moon hollow but
it's also a spacecraft that traveled
here in the distant past
so now we have to ask
who built the moon
[Music]
every ancient culture on earth has
stories about the moon but it's
interesting that the further back you go
the fewer stories there are and if you
go back far enough there are stories
that talk about a sky before the moon
arrived roman and greek authors in the
5th century bc have stories about the
proselynes and they lived in an area
called arcadia and they said they've
been here since before there was a moon
in the heavens on the other side of the
world the ancient culture of tiwanaka in
bolivia also refers to a time when there
was no moon the tuanaka claim the moon
arrived between 11 500 and 13 000 years
ago if you're into ancient theories as
much as i am you'll recognize that this
time coincides perfectly with a period
called the younger dryas and all kinds
of myths and mysteries are said to have
happened during the young adrias and
we'll cover them on this channel now
going back to africa there are zulu
legends that specifically say the moon
is hollow and living inside is an
intelligent race of reptilian
extraterrestrials is it people yep
lizard people built the moon
that's what they believe wizard people
are very industrious they seem to be the
zulu believe the moon was put into orbit
by two brothers who were gods and this
legend is similar to what the sumerians
believed the sumerians also had a legend
of two brothers enki and and lille who
were called annunaki yup anunnaki the
extraterrestrial gods who created
mankind everything is falling into place
with this one oh you ain't seen nothing
yet how about this the zulu also
believed that before the moon arrived
the climate of the earth was very
different there were no seasons and a
blanket of thick water vapor covered the
entire planet and we now know that the
moon does stabilize our climate without
the moon's gravity the earth's axis
would wobble there would be no
consistent seasons no tides extreme
weather the presence of the moon is what
allows life on earth to thrive
so back to the zulu the earth was
covered by a thick layer of water vapor
and you could only see the sun through
this hazy mist when the moon was finally
placed into orbit all this water vapor
fell at once and it created a
cataclysmic global flood always a flood
always every time every ancient culture
has a flood myth and there's mounting
evidence that this did indeed happen
during the younger dryas cultures around
the world have myths that are in perfect
sync with each other the coincidences
keep piling up the zulu legend talks
about how the arrival of the moon
changed the tides and stabilized the
climate and this is something that
wasn't understood by science until the
past hundred years yet somehow the
ancient zulu were able to make the
connection between the moon and the
tides and the seasons all of these myths
and legends plus strange coincidences
and anomalies about the moon start to
add up to a compelling theory that the
moon is hollow is artificial and was
placed here by intelligent beings long
ago but coincidences aren't proof and
myths aren't proof we need to know
what's been happening on the moon lately
to see if we can make our case with hard
evidence lucky for us
the evidence is there
science tells us that the moon is a cold
lifeless place it has no atmosphere
there hasn't been seismic activity for
millions of years its core unlike the
earth's is cold
for supposedly dead world there's an
awful lot of activity up there on march
7th 1971 a cloud of water vapor appeared
on the moon that covered a hundred
square miles and it was there for 14
hours before it dissipated there's not
supposed to be atmosphere on the moon
but for those 14 hours there was
in fact six astronomers in the past
hundred years have documented a glowing
mist in the crater named plato the same
mist the same crater over many years
boulder tracks are seen on the moon all
over the place and that's weird enough
but how do boulders roll for miles and
then go uphill like in this photo
and since the days of aristotle
astronomers have seen strange lights
appear on the surface of the moon
sometimes visible with the naked eye
nasa even reported that between the
years 1540 and 1967 there were 570
sightings of light flashes on the moon
that couldn't be explained
sightings of strange lights continued to
this day the aristarchus crater was
photographed in 1992 and it shows a
glowing blue light now called the blue
gem and this anomaly has been seen by
earth-based telescopes every few years
since some have even speculated it's a
fusion reactor and these events of
mysterious light and mist happen so
frequently but there's even a name for
them transient lunar phenomena or tlps
but things get even more weird there are
plenty of photographs of what appear to
be artificial objects on the surface of
the moon towers that reach several miles
high pyramids symmetrical structures
these have been photographed by
astronomers probes even the astronauts
themselves and the biggest anomaly of
all
why haven't we gone back to the moon
sergeant carl wolf was working as a
technician for the air force and he was
repairing equipment that transferred
images from a lunar satellite those
photos according to sergeant wolf showed
artificial structures on the moon what
he described as a base and this is
corroborated by another technician
working with wolf and wolf wasn't a ufo
e.t moon theory guy he was just a tech
he said he was excited to see the
pictures on the news and have nasa
explain what they were he was surprised
when the photos never turned up the
photos were found in a very early
release from nasa
these structures are very large and very
tall you can even see they cast shadows
and these are photos i'd like to learn
more about
but i can't they no longer exist
now almost immediately after landing on
the moon the apollo 11 crew said they
saw something that shook them up watch
the press conference they gave when they
returned these men aren't acting like
they made history or had a life-changing
experience
it's
a beginning of
a new age
they look sad frightened uncomfortable
even depressed
why is there a reason we haven't
returned to the moon and could it be
that the apollo missions discovered
something that ancient cultures knew
centuries ago
something that reputable scientists
believe is the only answer to this list
of mysteries that the moon is not what
it seems or what we've been told the
moon is hollow artificially constructed
and appeared in earth's orbit from
somewhere else far away makes sense to
me
does it make sense to you
[Music]
so what can science explain about the
hollow moon spaceship theory well the
formation of the moon is still unknown
so score theory one science zero the
density problem is said to be because
after the giant impact the earth's upper
mantle form the moon the mantle is much
less dense than the core
okay the problem with this is the giant
impact theory probably isn't what
happened
and the theory about the earth and the
moon forming out of that big donut shape
i'm in geometry that's called a taurus
taurus
well that wouldn't explain the density
discrepancy we're told the moon ringing
like a bell is because the moon is much
less dense and the moon's rock has much
less water so vibrations reverberate
longer and farther this can't be proven
but okay the perfect eclipses well
here's where science wins the eclipses
aren't exact they're close but not
perfect besides the moon is drifting
farther away from the earth every year
so eclipses are becoming less and less
perfect all the time and whether the
moon arrived 14 000 years ago or was
formed billions of years ago it was much
closer to the earth so it was much
larger in the sky now nasa claims that
we know the moon isn't hollow because of
seismic observations and that's fair but
it's still conjecture look we don't know
for sure what's at the center of the
earth much less what's at the center of
the moon if there's anything at all
right
now the structures are said to be
shadows or optical illusions
and the lights are from meteor impacts
or reflections from glassy patches on
the surface nope but the bottom line is
this yes the hollow moon spaceship
theory is a wild one i admit that and
many of the anomalies found on the moon
can be explained the explanations aren't
perfect but they're enough to satisfy
skeptics and i consider myself a skeptic
but i'm open-minded i just want to know
the truth
when i started researching this story i
thought it would be a fun ride a pure
tinfoil hat experience that we could
button up with science that's not what
happened there's just so much unknown
and unexplainable that something doesn't
feel right about what we've been told
about the moon but as always the space
agencies and the governments they serve
are very selective about the images and
information they release so i have a
message for them for nasa the european
space agency russia china elon musk
richard branson jeff bezos and anyone
with the resources to put people back on
the moon the message is this
if you want us to believe your
explanations
you're gonna have to prove it
[Music]
all right
what's this i got a sponsor you've got a
sponsor why do you need a sponsor
inflation the fish food is costing me a
fin and a fin besides i'm getting killed
on bitcoin i told you to sell a little
total
all right so what is surf shark and why
do you need it it's a vpn
virtual a private network i know what a
vpn is well there are some shows i like
to watch but they're not available to
stream in the u.s so i i can change my
ip address to different countries to
watch them example well you know how
netflix dropped the office and now it's
on peacock or pigeon or whatever
cockamamie service that is yeah that
that was annoying well i can use an ip
address in the uk and still watch it for
free on netflix sounds kind of sneaky i
know i love it or i can use an ip
address in australia and watch the big
lebowski that is a good one the fish
abides and since my ip address is hidden
google and facebook can't track me oh
yeah you definitely don't want big
internet companies having access to your
data no not just companies government
too when i'm looking up information
about the moon landing which is
definitely fake none of those
three-letter agencies can track me and
jam me up
it's like a tin foil hat
for your internet
huh
nice catchphrase yeah you like that huh
i even got one of those code things so
people can get their own tinfoil hat for
their internet get surfshot vpn at
surfshot.deals
files and enter promo code files for 83
off and three extra months for free
that works out to only 249 a month
that's a small price to pay for security
and privacy that's surf shock dot deals
slash files
that was a pretty good sponsor read well
you aren't the only former radio
personality on this show you know
there was love in the rocks by neil
diamond for all you broken hearts
drowning your sorrows tonight and before
that we went all the way back to the
grove yard for a little classic marvin
gaye good evening lovers and lovettes my
name is hecklefish and you're taking a
midnight ride on w-a-v-e to wave with 55
minutes of love songs every hour keep it
locked into the wave because i can go
all night this next one is a long
distance dedication from sharon in
chicago she writes you've always had my
back you make me feel protected and safe
here's i'll be there just for you safe
shack
[Music]
get surfsharkvpn at surfshark.dl files
and enter promo code files for 83 off
and three extra months for free and not
bad thanks mine was better shut up
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment share
i hate to give you homework but that
stuff really helps out a small channel
and if you have a topic you'd like
covered or you have interesting
information to share
email tips at theywhyfiles.com putting
it in the comments is cool but i don't
want to miss it so use that email and
special thanks to our generous patrons
who make this channel possible we
couldn't do it without you
until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
you